And right now you are trespassing here.
And I want you to leave.
Welcome back everyone.
This is going to be my full Wandavision episode
4 video in Marvel Easter eggs.
There were so many references here they confirm
most my theories about what's really going
on with there were so many big reveals so
we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel and doing
videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything were
also doing a Disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you do to enter is be subscriber and just
post all your theories in the comments below
careful for spoilers.
If you have not seen the episode yet, but
all just number these as we go along and talk
about Easter eggs.
So the episode basically replace the events
of the first three episodes, but from swords
perspective is basically a sort of Monica
Rambeau episode, but it felt like a 30 minute
Marvel movie like give me the 30 minute version
of Avengers infinity war and Avengers endgame
because it starts with Monica Rambeau remembering
the events of her childhood, like the dialogue
scene here you hear Brie Larson's voice that
she was credited in the episodes of the reason
why she was in the credits is because they
were playing dialogue directly from the Captain
Marvel movie is basically her as a child,
remembering the events of the film.
She's waking up in a hospital next to what
she thought was her mother's bed.
So that's where she got snapped revealing
that she was snap like a lot of other people
during Avengers infinity war.
So what were seeing here is basically the
events of the blip as they play out in real
time like you see people like literally just
coming together in pieces it's like a reverse
version of being dusted literally just play
it in reverse.
The hospital room that she's in his room 104.
That's a bit of an Easter egg for Avengers
number 104 where Trask from the X-Men comics
is keeping scarlet witch trapped using her
power to set up this big solar flare which
he believes will sterilize the entire earth
of the X gene getting rid of all mutants and
the Avengers and vision have to save scarlet
witch I think that's a bit of an Easter egg
for what happens with the dome as they talk
about her reality warping powers her cosmic
radiation later in the episode all get into
that to because they reveal more about how
her cosmic powers worked that just her comic
book reality warping ability they really are
taking scarlet witch OP during the series
Kevin Feige said they were joking around she's
gonna go full comic book scarlet witch she's
running around people and chaos.
Even the doctors going crazy like I have to
call my family.
I don't have time to treat patients.
We find out that her mother Maria Rambeau
that they reference several times in the episode
has actually died of cancer in her old age.
That's the reason she was in the hospital,
but even though her operation was successful
because she wasn't snapped.
She survived, but the cancer came back to
she want to die a couple years later during
that five year time gap this whole opening
scene, though, is sort of an answer to the
questions that everyone were asking the Russo's
went Avengers endgame came out, like, what
would happen if all the people who were snapped
while they were flying an airplane 30,000
feet in the air when the hold also be snapping
them back 30,000 feet in the air with the
rematerialize with no plane and then just
fall to their deaths than a three-week time
jump later after the events of Avengers endgame
we pick up a swords headquarters on earth
sort of like the sword version of shield project
Pegasus base and the answer a lot of questions
about how long it's been around how it was
created, how it coexisted with shield this whole time.
Even though we know that Monica Rambeau was
a sort agent from all the trailers months
and months ago we saw the symbol on her necklace
back during episode three with scarlet witch
went off Thanos on her with their very careful
to let the camera linger in the lobby on this giant version.
of the symbol just to help people make that connection.
The also spent a lot of time explaining what
sword does exactly and how it's different
from shield and a lot of what they do is in
outer space and how that's changed because
of what happened during Avengers infinity
war with the snap Thanos and then Avengers
endgame and the blip you see all these orbital
launch platforms because they were largely
a space agency before the events of Avengers
infinity war, but they made some changes during
the five-year time jump just because things
got so crazy on planet Earth, but this is
the connection to Nick Fury's sword space
station with the scrolls from the Spider-Man
far from home post credit scene that just
another part of their facility.
They have in space where they conduct missions
from the acronym stands for sentiment weapon
observation and response division their very
careful to leave that up on the TV frame so
people can read it for a long time and then
Monica Rambeau also later references it later
when she's talking to him about their new
weapons research like wait a minute, what
happened to the observant response part he's
like all things got tough.
We had to start making a whole bunch of weapons.
You also keep in mind that beings like scarlet
witch vision mutants cosmic beings like galacticus
Celestial's Thanos eternal's which will meet
hopefully later this year.
Please Marvel don't keep delaying your movies
anymore.
Those are all the senti and weapons that they're
talking about.
You also notice of the monitors the lobby
sort of helping you chart the timeline you
see all the news broadcast of people celebrating
the street you see that WHIH news broadcast
there like Marvel's in universe version of
CNN that showed up through Marvel phase 1,
phase 2 and phase 3 movies Monica Rambeau
enters to have a meeting with the new director
and they sort of explain what her relationship
with sword was before this point her mother
helped create it after the events of the Captain
Marvel movie in combination with Nick Fury
and shield she had to think of sword as a
branch agency of shield and she was just working
with Nick Fury her mother was the former director
of sword.
They reveal that Monica Rambeau grew up at
this facility.
Obviously of the earlier version of it.
The price changed over time with new technology
the Tyler Heyward director character.
She meets with the just a former colleague
who did not get snap, so they kind of explained
that she probably would've wound up taking
her mother job and becoming the director sort
the new version of Nick Fury at sword had
she not been snapped a lot of people wondering
if this guy is gonna wind up secretly being
a skrull in disguise because they have the
Nick Fury Avengers secret invasion series
coming up, which the be a lot of sword stuff
happening during that is always possible,
but we don't know much about him.
So we'll see what they reveal about his character
in future episodes.
There any clues about that you notice the
sign with all the different areas inside the base.
They have flight crew operations life systems
thermal systems mechanics lab maintenance
area avionics integration mission control
mission operations.
Visitors viewing area flight dynamics mission
simulation that just remind you that is kind
of like a shield version of NASA and mostly
at least before Avengers infinity war.
They were concerned with spaceflight missions,
but now as he says they're moving more to
artificial intelligence stuff which is getting
into more Iron Man and Avengers tech like
he says they lost a bunch of their astronauts
training because they got the lift and when
they came back there like hell no I'm not
doing anymore the space missions anymore,
but when you talk about robotics AI that stuff
like visions technology there now in the business
of creating literal and metaphorical senti
and weapons as well.
Some of you also probably notice is really
cool Easter egg for Avengers infinity war
here when they're walking past the construction
of all the spaceships and this technology
lying around here look at this engine part
here.
This is the same advanced engine that Iron
Man had inside the Avengers base during Avengers Infinity war.
Some of you may remember this, a couple years ago
there was a big joke about this item because
the Russo brothers tweeted this mysterious
picture of it out before they release the
first trailer and the entire Internet, myself
included, were going crazy trying to figure
out what it was supposed to be like is the
supposed to be a new weapon that the gonna
use during the movie.
Nope.
Turns out it was just a really advanced engine
that was sitting in the background in the
Avengers base then everyone of using a during
that movie, but apparently here the gonna
be using it was sword.
So this just confirming the sword got their
hands a lot of Ironman and Avengers technology
after and game, when he talks about enemies
and threats from outer space.
He's talking about Thanos mostly Enos and
the infinity gauntlet is also a bit of foreshadowing
for all the fantastic four galactic Celestial
stuff is good to be happening.
Obviously the Thor movies are very cosmic
to threats from outer space.
But when she talks about friends and allies
from space.
She's also talking about for the skrulls,
because most of the skrulls are good within
the MCU right now.
I'll get into more that when we talk about
the secret invasion series, because there
will be skrulls that are doing bad things
during that per Kevin Feige so not every single
skrull is going to be a good character or
office inside.
Here's room 101 that might be an Easter egg
for Avengers 101 which is another scarlet
witch and Quicksilver Avengers story about
them having to save the world from this all-powerful
person who goes around killing a bunch of
innocent people thinking that he's saving
the world doing a good thing, but secretly
winds up being the villain.
The whole time.
I think that's a bit of foreshadowing for
the reveal that scarlet witch is the villain
of this episode at least the villain of the
series Wandavision.
So far, ultimately I don't think the idea
is to demonize her as the true villain of
the series they could beat more complex things
and play people manipulating her, but right
now she's meant to be the villain of the series
and when he talks about the FBI case the missing
persons case you remember it's only been three
weeks since the end of Avengers endgame that
this is started that explains why Jimmy Wu
shows up from San Francisco like what you
doing all the way over here.
Oh what you had somebody in witness protection
who just disappeared and nobody even his family
remembers who he is, does even know he exists
anymore.
That's the crazy thing that kind of lets you
know how powerful scarlet witch is and how
much her ability is affecting everyone's all
talk about that in the second to he also uses
her Captain name when Monica Rambeau takes
off that just another reminder about her origin
as the second version of Captain Marvel in
the comics.
Remember she was Captain Marvel long before
Carol Danvers became Captain Marvel in the
comics and over, but is wondering when she's
gonna get her powers will happen during Wandavision
will happen during the Captain Marvel two
movie because that's where she can show up
next my assumption is, though just tease that
and then they'll pay that off a little bit
more during the actual movie, but then she
has the West you they confirm that it's in
New Jersey not too far from the former Avengers
base and the New York City area because most
of the bigger events on earth and the MCU
take place in and around this part of the
country is a lot of West Coast stuff happening
during marble phase for over on the other
side, the United States, so I believe that
Westview the name is also a bit of a reference
to West Coast Avengers, like, what happens
after the regular Avengers well you have the
West Coast Avengers.
We find of the Jimmy Wu has perfected his
close-up magic release gotten better at it.
That's what five years with of online magic
courses will get you.
I'm hoping if they pay off my theory about
Doctor Strange showing up on the series crossing
over, because the doctor Strange two step
that he'll have a scene with him and also
try to show off for Doctor Strange like oh
your sorcerer I'm something of a magician
myself to it and boom kind of magic a card
of forum there a lot of record drop jokes
like that would Jimmy Wu during the episode.
I felt like he was edgy pretty fantastic.
He and Darcy together.
There's some great scenes.
But then they reveal how scarlet witch is
alternate reality is affecting everyone else
mentally trying to keep everyone out the sort
of effect where it basically repels people
as much as possible sort of messes with their
minds to make them forget that Westview even exists.
So like, post all the means Westview no no no
I'm from Eastview they revealed that there's
3,892 people living inside the town.
The dome itself, like the barrier is about
a 5 mile radius was actually really big Darcy
also later in the episode talks about how
it might wind up getting bigger, to which
I think is more full-blown house of M references
that they're making like oh no, this could
get much worse and eventually cover the entire
planet when she's pulling out the drone the
license plate for her car.
I believe that's a bit of a reference to the
Wandavision funko pop that they made for the
show because the one provisions character
is number 718.
That's right.
They are selling pops for the Wandavision
series of course are gonna sell toys for all
the different Marvel Disney plus series.
The also confirmed that the blue drone that
she tries to fly in is the red drone that
shows up during episode 2 and it just changes
because of the way her reality warping powers
change to make it fit the scenario of the
1960s.
The also sort of pay off that reference with
the beekeeper from episode 2.
As well, you find that he's just a regular
sort agent it wearing a hazmat suit and when
he crosses the barrier scarlet witch's reality
warping powers just change him to fit the scenario.
So he looks period specific.
like the lifeline that he's hooked
up to changes into a jump rope and it also
exists on the outside to I keep talking about
this, but it's more confirmation that the
fake things that she creates with her reality
warping powers inside this alternate reality
will continue to exist in the real world more
of a reference to Wiccan and speed Billy and
Tommy her children existing after the events
of Wandavision like yes there fake, but they
will continue to be real and go to a young
Avengers crossover's in future Marvel Disney
plus series.
But then they can for my theory about her
touching the barrier getting sucked in like
she's literally and metaphorically getting
sucked into a TV show through the TV screen
and 24 our time jump later the rest of the
sword bases gone up and we check back in with
Darcy welcome back from all the for movies.
She starts talking about cosmic microwave
background radiation which is just another
reference to comic book scarlet witch powers
of reality warping and chaos magic like literally
altering things on a massive massive scale
that.
So OP scarlet witch in the MCU is now though
get into that more in future episodes and
explain how it works, and just exactly how
powerful she is.
That's where you start spinning up and the
big Doctor Strange level stuff, but when Darcy
says that that radiation is only contained
to this area for right now.
She sort of implying that eventually it might
cover the entire earth.
So the entire earth might start changing reality
everywhere, for everyone will start warping
according to what scarlet Witch wants.
So they're taking the MCU full-blown house
of M. That's where you get to the reverse.
No more mutants of it all, like potential
for her to create mutants all over the world
with her reality warping abilities.
Then she detects the TV waves that are superimposed
and they start watching the naked night episodes
play out like wait a minute.
What's happening here.
They keep referencing the hexagon pattern
like you see Jimmy was whiteboard here, like,
what's going on why hexagons she reminds us
the vision is supposed to be dead.
Not look back, which is foreshadows the big
twist at the end of the episode that vision
is still dead and scarlet witch has been weekend
and burning him walking around with his body
like a puppet this whole time we'll talk about
that in a second too that was one of the biggest
moments of the episode and the series.
So far that they have the montage of them
slowly identifying all the townspeople putting
their pictures and their IDs up on the board
notice that Agnes does not have an ID she's
the only person here that they can't find
a name for that's why she doesn't have a last
name he just reads Agnes the we all believe
that she's going to be a version of Agatha
Harkness from the comics it if she is that
would imply that she's also magic user like
Doctor Strange and she has some sort of ability
low-level powers that help her counteract
what scarlet witch is doing, which is why
she's one of the few people that seems like
she's not totally affected by what's happening.
It also seems that she's been manipulating
scarlet witch ever since the events of episode 1.
So maybe she has something to do with helping
scarlet witch create this alternate reality
or at least convincing her that it was possible
and she could do it that I love how they all
flip out when they see Monica Rambeau all
Stepford wives during the events of episode
2 like wait a minute issue pretending it sort
of explains how powerful scarlet witch is
ability are and that it alters people's memories
to fit each different scenario through the
different decades then they show you the other
side of the scene of Jimmy Wu and Darcy trying
to contact her using the radio in the events
of episode 2 Wanda.
Wanda, can you hear me, who's doing this to
you.
You also notice in the background you can
hear that Help me Rhonda beach boys song.
That's also a song about a guy trying to get
over his former girlfriend with another new
girl seated also called their use of this
song specifically another reference to scarlet
witch trying to use this house of M scenario
to process her grief over losing vision then
they watch one of scarlet witch is real-time
edits happen where she rewinds things only
for them, it just plays out like a TV episode
jump cut like wait a minute, what just happened
and they revealed the Darcy and the other
sword agents in the real world can see the
commercials just like we would see in a normal
TV show like there's actual commercial breaks
in the broadcast feed they're getting from
inside the alternate reality.
The reason the commercials are playing out
and the sitcoms are happening this way, like
a TV broadcast would is because it's all coming
from scarlet witch is subconscious and that's
why the events of the commercials are mostly
references to her past her origin like they
talk about stroker stroker will make time
for you.
That's her sort of processing all the things
that have happened to her.
The major events of her life, but because
is a bit of a subconscious thing.
She's not totally aware of the way that it's
happening and how it's manifesting for other
people like she doesn't know that the people
in the real world are watching this play out
like a commercial than the jump forward to
the events of episode three and they start
wondering why the decades of TV why the 70s
80s 90s and 2000s also they can age her children
up to adults and they can go crossover with
other young Avengers characters in Marvel
Disney plus shows then they finally revealed
the end of episode three would really happen
where you see the aspect ratio change from
4 by 3 to the movie aspect ratio that's to
let you know when you're no longer quote of
quote in the matrix like simulation like this
is really happening in everyone sort of come
to their senses they start talking more about
Ultron and then she talks about her being
this interloper your trespassing in my home
and I want you to leave and she kicks her
a boom concert through the barrier like you
getting punted out of a TV screen.
I love Elizabeth Olsen's performance in this
ending scene here pretty much everything that
she does is just fantastic.
They should give her an award for this is
really horrified at what happened, because
she's come to her senses like wait a minute
all these terrible things that I came here to escape.
I'm thinking about them again.
She slowly starts to pull yourself back together
at the side of her children, but not before.
The big vision reveal big reveal that he still
very much dead make all the Weekend at Bernie
jokes and the reason why he's speaking like
that and she sees him that way then changes
back immediately is because she's changing
things on the fly with her reality warping
powers and desires.
So when he walks in because she still kind
of shaken from the Ultron Quicksilver reference
of Monica Rambeau she's thinking about vision
being dead and why she came here in the first place.
So literally he manifests that way until she
quickly recompose yourself and change them
back to his regular parents and they make
it very clear that vision is pretty much the
only person inside here that has no idea what's
going on.
He doesn't know that he's dead and every time
scarlet witch is changing things to sort of
reverse him and make him go back to normal
is to prevent him from learning that when
they make a reference about going anywhere
and she's like no we can't go anywhere.
This is our home.
That's because scarlet witch probably doesn't
know that her reality warping powers will
eventually potentially cover the entire planet
like she doesn't know how big it's going to
get that I love the way she goes out to.
She says I have everything under control like
she's deftly gone full-blown crazy town, but
that's just more comic book scarlet witch
references about her losing her mind, so to
speak and is probably pretty obvious why they're
making the Jimi Hendrix voodoo child reference
with the song track the lyrics reference superpowerful
person chopping mountains and have seen people.
After they died.
So scarlet witch is the voodoo child in the
metaphor, but if he spotted any big Easter
eggs in the episode that I didn't mention
the video just write them below in the comments.
There's so much happening now.
I feel like this is probably the best episode.
So far, and it's only supposed to get crazier
and bigger bigger Avengers level stuff happening
the rest of the episodes my full episode 5
video will post next Friday like normal, but
I'll do more bonus videos about what's going
on and scarlet witch in the MCU going forward
all the X-Men the mutants stuff is going on
the background all the big Doctor Strange
crossover stuff where you wait for everything.
Click here for my brand-new Wandavision Doctor
Strange to crossover video and click here
for all my other Wandavision episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe I'll see in the next video!